>> Tucker: IF THERE IS ONE
THING IN THE WORLD YOU
DEFINITELY SHOULDN'T WORRY ABOUT
IT'S THAT FAKE CENTRAL AMERICAN
MIGRANT CARAVAN THAT THIS IN A
PHONE XENOPHOBIC PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN TRYING TO GET YOU TO
BELIEVE IN.
FOLDING IS MADE UP, IT'S A
MIRAGE.
AND EVEN IF IT ISN'T, IT'S ON
THE FAR SIDE OF THE PLANET.
FAR FAR AWAY FROM HERE.
LISTEN TO SOME OF THE SMARTEST
PEOPLE ON THE PLANET TELL YOU
THAT YOUR FEARS ARE RIDICULOUS.
>> THEY ARE TELLING YOU THAT
IT'S A BUNCH OF POOR REFUGEES A
THOUSAND MILES AWAY.
SPEAK OUT THIS GROUP OF FOLKS,
WE DON'T EVEN KNOW WHERE THEY
ARE, THEY ARE WAY DOWN THERE.
>> CALLED THIS AN INVASION, IT
MIGHT BE THE MOST PATHETIC
INVASION IN HISTORY IF IT WERE
ACTUALLY AN INVASION BUT OF
COURSE IT'S NOT.
>> PEOPLE HE CALLED INVADERS
EVEN THOUGH THEY WERE A THOUSAND
MILES AWAY.
>> WAY DOWN THERE, A THOUSAND
IN OTHER WORDS, THE CARAVAN IS A
LOT LIKE SOCIAL SECURITY.
IT'S SOMETHING WE MIGHT
POTENTIALLY NEED TO THINK ABOUT
SOMEDAY BUT FOR NOW, EVERYTHING
IS TOTALLY FINE.
CALM DOWN.
WHAT LIARS THEY ARE.
IN FACT PARTS OF THAT SUPPOSEDLY
DISTANT CARAVAN HAVE ALREADY
MADE IT TO THE AMERICAN BORDER
AND MANY OF THE ILLEGAL MIGRANTS
IN IT HAVE ALREADY POPPED OUR
SHODDY DEFENSES AND ENTERED OUR
COUNTRY.
THE FAMOUS PEOPLE THAT YOU JUST
WATCHED HER CLAIM THAT WOULD
NEVER HAPPEN HAVEN'T ADMITTED
THEY WERE WRONG INTENTIONALLY OR
NOT, THEY HAVEN'T ISSUED
CORRECTIONS, OF COURSE AND THEY
NEVER WILL.
THE ELECTION IS OVER SO THEY ARE
ON TO THE NEXT TALKING POINT AND
MEANWHILE THE TORRENT CONTINUES.
DESPITE THE CARAVAN BEING A
METHOD INVENTED BY
PRESIDENT TRUMP FOR A MIDTERM,
MEANWHILE HENRIQUE AZEVEDO
MINISTER FIND IT.
I'M A LITTLE BIT CONFUSED.
LAST TIME I CHECKED WHICH WAS
JUST A COUPLE DAYS AGO IT SEEMS
LIKE THAT CARAVAN WAS IN
PRESIDENT OBAMA'S TERMS, A
THOUSAND MILES AWAY AND THEY
WERE WALKING.
HOW DID THEY GET TO TIJUANA?
>> THE CARAVAN IS VERY REAL.
IT'S A MOVEMENT OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE, AROUND 5,000 HAVE
ALREADY ARRIVED TO TIJUANA AND
THE BORDER WITH SAN DIEGO, BUT
IT'S NOT A NATIONAL EMERGENCY
AND IT'S NOT A THREAT TO
NATIONAL SECURITY OF THE
UNITED STATES.
MOST OF THE PEOPLE THAT ARE PART
OF THIS CARAVAN ARE JUST PUSHING
STROLLERS THROUGH MEXICO.
THEY ARE FAMILIES, WOMEN AND
BABIES JUST TRYING TO GET TO THE
U.S. TO ILLEGALLY REQUEST ASYLUM
WHICH PRESIDENT TRUMP IS MAKING
MUCH HARDER.
>> I JUST WANT TO GET TO THE
PRACTICAL PART OF THIS.
WE WERE TOLD BY ANCHORS ACROSS A
SPECTRUM ON TELEVISION THAT THE
CARAVAN WAS A THOUSAND MILES
AWAY.
THEY WERE WALKING.
IT WOULD BE WEEKS BEFORE THEY
GOT TO OUR BORDER.
I WAKE UP THIS MORNING AND THERE
THEY ARE, HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?
DID THEY RUN OR DID SOMEONE PAY
BUSES TO TAKE THEM UP HERE?
YOU DIDN'T TELL US THAT PART.
>> IT TOOK THEM ALMOST A MONTH
FOR OVER A MONTH TO GET FROM THE
HONDURAS TO THE U.S. AND MEXICO
BORDER.
NOT ALL OF THEM HAVE ARRIVED,
SOME OF THEM THEM ARE STILL
TRYING TO GET TO THIS POINT.
SOME OF THEM CAUGHT A RIDE AND
WERE ABLE TO GET ON BUSES AND
TRAILERS OF CHICKENS AND PIGS.
>> Tucker: THAT'S NOT QUITE
RIGHT.
>> SOME OF THEM ARE TRYING TO
REACH THE BORDER.
>> Tucker: SO YOU ARE SAYING
NOBODY CHARTERED ANY BUSES TO
BRING THEM UP HERE?
BECAUSE I THINK WE HAVE VIDEOS
SHOWING CHARTERED BUSES BRINGING
THEM UP HERE.
YOU DON'T THINK THERE ARE ANY
CHARTERED BUSES WHATSOEVER?
>> I HAVEN'T SEEN ANYONE
CHARTERING BUSES.
I'VE SEEN MEXICAN OFFICIALS
PROVIDING TRANSPORTATION FROM
THIS POINT IN THE BORDER, IT'S
HERE WHERE 800 PEOPLE ARE
SPENDING THE NIGHT.
THEY ARE BEING TRANSPORTED IN
BUSES FROM HERE TO THERE BUT NOT
FROM OAXACA TO THE BORDER.
>> Tucker: YOU MAY WANT TO
CHECK YOUR SOURCES ON THAT,
BECAUSE IT WOULD BE IMPOSSIBLE
FOR THAT GROUP TO MOVE
ESPECIALLY WITH THE STROLLERS
THAT YOU CLAIM ARE THERE, YOU
ARE SAYING IT'S MAJORITY WOMEN
AND BABIES IN STROLLERS?
IS THAT WHAT YOU ARE SAYING?
>> I AM HAPPY TO SHARE THE
FOOTAGE WITH FOX NEWS FROM OUR
CORRESPONDENT WHO TRAVELED WITH
THEM IN THE BACK OF A BUS THAT
USUALLY CARRIES CHICKENS.
THAT'S HOW THEY GOT TO -- AND
THAT'S WHAT I HAVE TO SHARE WITH
YOU.
>> Tucker: WHAT I'M SAYING IS
YOU ARE ENGAGING IN PROPAGANDA
DESIGNED TO MAKE PEOPLE THINK
SOMETHING THAT IS NOT TRUE.
SO I THINK THE MAJORITY OF
PEOPLE, INCLUDING THE PEOPLE ON
THE TAPE MOVING FROM HONDURAS
AND GUATEMALA ARE YOUNG MEN
WITHOUT THEIR WIVES AND
CHILDREN, RIGHT?
>> I DON'T THINK ANYONE WAS
QUESTIONING THE EXISTENCE OF THE
CARAVAN.
WHAT THEY WERE QUESTIONING IS
THE LABEL OF BEING A NATIONAL
THREAT, WITH GETTING THE TROOPS
TO THE BORDER.
>> IT'S VERY HARD -- IT'S VERY
HARD TO MAKE RATIONAL DECISIONS
ABOUT HOW TO RESPOND TO
SOMETHING IF YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT
IT IS BECAUSE EVERYONE ON TV IS
LYING TO YOU.
IT'S VERY CLEAR THAT EVERYONE ON
TV IS LYING TO US AND THEY TOLD
US IT WOULD BE WEEKS BEFORE THIS
CARAVAN WOULD GET HERE BECAUSE
THEY WERE WALKING AND THAT WAS
ALIVE.
THEY SAID IT WAS MOSTLY WOMEN
AND CHILDREN, THAT WAS ALIVE.
SO UNTIL WE GET TO THE FACTS, WE
CAN'T KNOW HOW TO RESPOND.
SO LET'S STOP WITH THE LYING AND
TO TELL US WHAT IS ACTUALLY
GOING ON.
AND YOU KNOW AS WELL AS I COME
IT'S MOSTLY ECONOMIC MIGRANTS
LOOKING FOR HIGHER WAGES IN THE
UNITED STATES.
I'M NOT ATTACKING THEM BUT
THAT'S A REALITY.
>> THERE IS NO ORGANIZED EFFORT
TO GET THESE MIGRANTS FROM THE
BORDER TO THE U.S.-MEXICO
BORDER.
I KNOW VICE PRESIDENT PENCE SAID
THERE WERE FORCES IN
LATIN AMERICA FINANCING THIS AND
MAKING IT SOME SORT OF A
CONSPIRACY TO UNDERMINE THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT, BUT THE REALITY THAT
THESE PEOPLE ARE PLAYING
HONDURAS, 300 UNDUE RESIDENTS
ARE LEAVING THE COUNTRY EVERY
DAY AND THEY DO THAT BECAUSE OF
THE LEVELS OF VIOLENCE AND
EXTREME POVERTY THAT THEY FACE.
SO WHAT WOULD YOU DO?
THIS IS NOT IDEAL.
THIS IS A HUMANITARIAN CRISIS.
>> SO YOU ARE SAYING THAT THERE
ARE NO GROUPS FUNDED BY
GOVERNMENTS OR BIG NGOs
HELPING THIS GROUP OF PEOPLE
MOVE FROM CENTRAL AMERICA TO
WHERE THEY ARE NOW IN TIJUANA?
TO GET ACROSS THE BORDER?
NOBODY IS HELPING THEM AND IT'S
ALL ORGANIC?
>> IN ALL OUR REPORTING, SINCE
THIS CARAVAN STARTED, NOT ONLY
THIS ONE BUT THE OTHERS THAT I
WILL CONTINUE TO FOLLOW, WE
HAVEN'T FOUND ANY EVIDENCE OF
ANY GOVERNMENT INVOLVING FUNDING
OR FINANCING THIS EFFORT TO TRY
TO GET THESE PEOPLE FROM
HONDURAS TO THE U.S.-MEXICO
BORDER.
MEXICAN PEOPLE HAVE BEEN KIND
ENOUGH TO PROVIDE SOME
HUMANITARIAN HELP BUT THERE IS
NO GOVERNMENT OR STATE FORCE
BEHIND THIS.
>> Tucker: IT WE ALL KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT'S GOING ON, I JUST
WANT TO HAVE YOU ON THE RECORD
SO WE CAN INVITE YOU BACK AND
TALK THROUGH YOUR PREVIOUS
CLAIMS AND COMPARE THEM TO THE
OTHER TENANTS THAT WE ARE IN THE